hello the following video your bets wash
was created by myself an auntie bellman
at pack south in Texas with the help of
all these wonderful people missiles
monthly reduce dogs on video game six
and three video games are stuck on three
Phoenix front and ghost trick and
probably ought to other two things it's
like you own those digital actors st.
dog so I don't know whatever the dogs
cool I like it's one of the best
assistant Marvis got my 50s right fuchs
price really better care to that game
but whatever it's really cool uh okay
I'll talk to delight oh gosh all right
Sleeping Dogs it was my game of the year
it's an open world game with martial
arts that actually works and it's fun to
play the dlc wasn't garbage there was
actually deal see that was good and it
started as a true-crime game which ended
up being awesome and like an open-world
game it's not a GTA game that's still
good so yeah some dogs able to dog the
dog that I was willing to give up my
friends my family all my fortune to at
the end of the game because I miss him
and he jumped in the way of a gunshot
poor feeble dog but alas I like my
family better sorry Babel dog but I
still up dude so yeah the old comic dog
the dog is from okami her name is
Amaterasu she's the Sun God I'm a trust
was a very crisp easy name to say Danny
it's not really hard it's a tough row
suit she's super cool cuz she's the
goddess goddess of the Sun and you know
she's just I gotta keep stretching
alright fine then you know why she's
cool she's got paintbrush powers and it
was an awesome game by clover and clover
is awesome and you know the thing about
games and whatever
chopped a dog another thing a dog I'm a
fat dog which is kind of cool to see it
was a good game over you know for a GTA
game open-world three-person canoe but
anyways it was a dog any of this team
have sex and first-person which I loved
and everyone should have loved because I
loved not the time job we gotta go
coming out of the vaults I developed
this really like loner personality and
dog me was the only companion that I
could really stand like that's super
mutant at the end of the game he just
screamed everything yeah I couldn't deal
with that and also like to you only had
one companion so like leaving one would
make you have to like say goodbye about
me which was like the end of one of
those really sad dog movies okay and
yeah dog needs the best and he's the
only one I could stand back on hug from
duck hunt on the NES but hey you can
download it on the Virtual Console but
back to duck hunt duck hunts duck on dog
he has that annoying laugh you probably
hate him for it and if you really want
to beat him up hey that's why we have
super smash brothers
I like Sam from salmon max games because
as a woman on the internet I need
someone wearing a fedora I can look up
to and also his partner is a psychotic
rabbit and I mean really that's I mean
that's pretty unique in and of itself
and also I think he played poker in one
game and I kind of like poker what up
dis is snoop the game got bad reviews
because the controls didn't play fine
snoop made the list even though you're
not a canine I played it just a little
he is my nizzle love this game hey for
shizzle yo he's got number two from the
start on his wrist but in number one
he'll be in my heart
you gotta do what I gotta believe kick
punch block it's all in the mind if you
want to test me I say you'll find
parappa the rappa is number one why
because he's had a whole generation of
gamers like myself rhythm and as a
result I used it to pick up girls just
like he picked up Sally number one hands
down the other guy snoop was pimp but
it's over Parappa
you